tf1 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
30 des 60 otages de l'ambassade
américaine de téhéran signé une pétition
pour implorer l'extradition du shah
seuls admis à l'inhumation de madame de
gaulle sa famille et quelques
personnalités gaulliste le film le
pull-over rouge la cour d'appel de paris
ordonne la suppression de quatre
séquences qui portait atteinte à la vie
privée
un succès pour l'aérospatiale
hélicoptères français twinstar déjà
vendu à 180 exemplaires avant même la
fin de tous les essais
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
monsieur yasser arafat a confirmé
aujourd'hui que l'ol paie l'organisation
de libération de la palestine devraient
par tous les moyens en faveur de la
libération des otages américains retenus
à téhéran le président de l'ol paie a
donné ces précisions à beyrouth au
chargé d'affaires de l'ambassade du
maroc le roi hassan ii était en effet
intervenu auprès de l'ol paie afin que
les otages américains détenus à téhéran
soient libérés
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine entretient en effet
d'excellents rapports avec le nouveau
gouvernement iraniens et en particulier
avec celui de l'oeil avec l'ayatollah
khomeini mais pour l'instant la
soixantaine d'otages est toujours entre
les mains des étudiants islamiques sur
place le point avec notre envoyé spécial
thierry de scitivaux
l'événement de la journée a été sans
cesse de la vigne se dire cette
américaine à bagdad faisait pays et
l'ambassadeur émirati à merci je prends
le pen invitée par le comité
l'occupation rendu à l'écu de
l'abbatiale à 15 heures pour être
conduit aussitôt dans ce local annexe à
garder en plein vol et se demander dans
une zone dont les listes ont été
obstruées par des papiers journaux pour
les produire auprès des autres halle
berry adultes sanitaires se devait
permettre aux ambassadeurs du monde il a
dit que les otages étaient en bonne
santé et cela pour vendredi regarder les
allégations de la presse américaine
alors aujourd'hui ambassadeur d'israël
au nom de ses collègues lancé réseau
allocution dont le fait valider le
brésil avait reçu l'accord des résumés
et d'autun travaux prévus ensuite de la
prévenue par france 3 otages réclamant à
l'état une lettre d'un certain garde
pourrait le fou ou écrivez à sa peine il
avait les pieds les animés et doute que
le président vient faire le vrai plus de
préoccuper du sort de ses concitoyens
seul et celui du mit dans cet art est
fier de vous l'un est que pour la
première fois lundi radio am a fait de
radio radio sur toi viens profiter les
autres
leur part les cas la guerre il va
falloir interpréter guérilleros et femme
errant aux états unis la colère grandit
et il ya eu de violents incidents qui
ont opposé des étudiants iraniens à des
contre-manifestants américain à propos
de cette affaire de prise d'otages à
l'ambassade des etats-unis à téhéran le
président carter ne peut pas avancer
dans cette affaire encore qu'une
opération militaire ne soit pas tout à
fait exclure la notte notamment la
proche de deux bateaux de la sixième
flotte américaine dont la mission reste
évidemment confidentielles
le point de washington avec l'envoyé
spécial permanent de tf1 dominique
bromberger
de l'atlantique au pacifique on a pu
voir se dérouler à souffraient les mêmes
scènes au cours des dernières 24 heures
des manifestations d'étudiants iraniens
provoquant les contre manifestations
parfois condamnées par quoi préparer
d'américains ce qui pages de toutes
catégories sociales
sovo d'étudiants iraniens ont parfois
par se dit grosse de 40 à 44 tonnes
l'outil à washington au cours d'une
manifestation de 900 personnes
l amérique latine a répondu dictée de ce
sport du bisou d'un manger votre pétrole
volé du roi notamment à los angeles
c'est qu'on est passé et on a brûlé des
drapeaux iraniens au cours d'incidents
relativement isolé et dans certains cas
très violents toute l'amérique essayé
d'une espèce de sueur du à l'humiliation
qu'elle a quatre et allianz l'ensemble
de la classe de démocrates que de
républicains proposent constamment c'est
contre l humanité calme que vous voulez
sauver la vie des otages
le président carter ne suis pas la
maison blanche ce week-end là pour
suivre les opérations alors que se
dessine peut-être les progrès d'une
évolution de la situation où est le fait
que la ja cela est accepté de recevoir
le nom du val de cèze adoption de
mesures tous la médiation de l'eau
n'guessan le progressé au point tel que
libération pourrait être envisagée dans
un avenir à ce que le franc suisse
officiellement le département d'état ne
se laisse pas aller un peu mais concède
que les discussions se font en revanche
la pétition remise aux ambassadeurs par
les otages pétition qui demande
l'expulsion de chasse a provoqué cette
réaction de la maison blanche
cela ne changera rien à notre position
une coupe a dû ronger kiosque du sous la
contrainte
dominique bromberger claude van damme le
secrétaire général de l'onu est
intervenu à son tour il a déclaré qu'il
était prêt à participer une tentative de
règlement pour faire pour mettre fin à
la prise d'otages de l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran et le nonce
apostolique également a été reçu par
l'ayatollah khomeiny il lui a transmis
un message du pape jean paul ii enfin le
président de l'onu à l'unité africaine a
également lancé un appel à l'ayatollah
khomeiny lui demandant d'intervenir afin
de faire libérer les otages de
l'ambassade des états unis
c'est dans la plus stricte intimité
contre lieu les obsèques de madame de
gaulle ainsi qu'elle l'avait souhaité
plusieurs barrages de gendarmerie ont
délimité un périmètre interdit à la
foule depuis ce matin c'est à 16h cet
après midi que madame de gaulle a été
inhumé dans le petit cimetière de
colombey les deux églises où reposent
déjà le général de gaulle sur place
l'envoyé spécial de tf1 bernard les
églises a dit son dernier adieu à l'une
de ses paroissiennes yvonne de gaulle
elle souhaitait des funérailles simple
un team familial six dernières volontés
furent respectée et la cérémonie s'est
déroulée dans la simplicité
comme on a l'habitude ici de le faire à
14h50 la dépouille mortelle de madame de
gaulle arrive devant la petite église où
les quelque 80 personnes de la famille
les habitants du village et les amis ont
déjà pris place
on remarque jacques chaban delmas
jacques chirac michel debré madame
pompidou rend les brouillet et bien
d'autres
le soleil a remplacé la grêle mais le
froid persiste les habitants de
collombey portent le cercueil
le curé et deux prêtres native de la
paroisse célèbre l'office à la demande
de la famille la presse audiovisuelle
n'a pas accès à l'église le prêtre
dirige la prière le latin alterne avec
le français après l'évangile quelques
phrases de l'abbé lambert le curé pour
rappeler que la charité de la défunte
fut apprécié qu'elle aura fait parti du
peuple des doux de ceux qui savent
ouvrir leurs mains à la fin de la messe
personnes défilent autour du cercueil
seule la famille assiste à l'inhumation
dans le petit cimetière
madame de gaulle rejoint ainsi sa fille
anne morte en 1948 et son mari décédé en
1970 le grand moment de la réunion
comme devait le souligner le prêtre de
la paroisse et puis les amis connus et
inconnus se sont inclinés devant le
caveau familial dit de gaulle un petit
millier de personnes a pris aujourd'hui
le chemin de colombey les deux églises
60 minutes de recueillement à l'église
et au cimetière
c'était la jet ou simple à madame de
gaulle l'illustrent violoncelliste
espagnol pablo cazals décédé il ya cinq
ans a reçu un hommage posthume hier
après midi à barcelone
le cercueil contenant la dépouille
mortelle
le plateau de pablo cazals a été
recouvert du drapeau catalan est
accompagné des drapeaux espagnols
français américains portoricain ainsi
que de l'emblème des nations unies des
messages ont été adressés par deux
hautes personnalités ont été lus par le
président de la généralité de catalogne
parmi ces messages celui du président
valéry giscard d'estaing et celui du
président américain jimmy carter pablo
cazals était décédé en 1973 à porto rico
après un longue exil que le
violoncelliste s'étaient imposés afin de
protester contre la dictature franquiste
manifestation houleuse à belfort autour
de la préfecture où a eu lieu la réunion
de conciliation entre syndicats et
dirigeants d'alstom atlantique
la réunion s'est poursuivie cet après
midi elle s'est terminée tout à l'heure
par un échec
les syndicalistes souhaitent une réunion
avec la direction parisienne du groupe
alston la direction de l'entreprise
s'est refusé jusqu'à présent à toute
déclaration
ce constat de non conciliation traduit
donc une rupture certaine entre la
direction et les syndicats en grève
depuis 45 jours
ils rendent ce fait exécutoire
l'évacuation de lusine de belfort
ordonnée par la cour d'appel de besançon
dans son arrêt du 25 octobre à
l'occasion de l'ouverture du congrès de
la fédération des métaux cgt aujourd'hui
la cfdt a été accusé par la cgt qui a
dénoncé je cite l'hésitation de la cfdt
à s'engager dans les luttes
à noter qu'aux élections
professionnelles à l'électricité au gaz
de france la cgt reste en tête avec 55%
des voix mais perd 1%
la cfdt arrive en deuxième position avec
21% mais gagne 2,5 pour cent force
ouvrière est au troisième rang avec un
peu plus de 12% des voix et perd 0,3
pour cent à lyon la grève va se
poursuivre dans les transports en commun
métro et bus ainsi en a décidé une
assemblée générale à laquelle
participent et 600 salariés sur les 1700
roulant des transports en commun
lyonnais
la grève qui en est à son cinquième jour
provoque des embouteillages considérable
les éditions mondiales l'un des plus
grands empires de presse en france créée
par cino del duca vont désormais être
contrôlé par un groupe de sociétés
d'assurances parmi elles
les mutuelles unies l'ua paix est une
filiale de la bnp
la veuve de monsieur cino del duca qui
reste pdg du groupe va céder environ 70
% de ses parts le montant de la
transaction est de 400 millions de
francs
un dossier signé jacques le rêve à bon
marché c'est parce qu chino del duca a
été le premier à l'offrir à ses lecteurs
que c'était migrer italien anti fasciste
est parvenu à créer à la fois un nouveau
style de presse celle du coeur et un
empire
les éditions mondiale dirigée
aujourd'hui par sa veuve plus d'un
milliard de francs de chiffre d'affaires
et 4 hebdomadaire télé poche second
titre français par sa diffusion
un million huit cent mille exemplaires
mode de paris plus de 800 milles et de
représentants de cette fameuse presse du
coeur nous deux et intimité qui depuis
plus de 30 ans font pleurer dans les
chaumières un groupe colossal donc avec
en plus vie filiale dont modes et
travaux la vie des métiers une
imprimerie une agence de publicité et
ses réussites exemplaires que celle de
cet empire avec une défaite pourtant
dans son histoire la mort en 72 de paris
jour qui malgré une formule originale
gros titres accrocheurs et format
tabloïd a sombré corps et biens
après treize ans d'existence et voilà
qu'aujourd'hui simone del doucas cède
environ 70 % de ses parts à un groupe de
compagnies d'assurance françaises
les structures du journal ne seront
nullement modifier elle reste pdg
alors pourquoi cette décision pourquoi
ce choix
pour empêcher dit-elle un groupe de
presse quelconque de contrôler lempire
del duca et ainsi de changer l'esprit et
le ton de ces publications
je vais vous dire que j'ai atteint
aujourd'hui l'âge qu'avait mon mari
lorsqu'il est décédé
je n'ai pas d'enfant et j'ai pensé qu'il
serait très imprudent de ma part de ne
pas prendre des dispositions de mon
vivant alors que je me sens encore très
bien
je dois vous l'avouer j'ai souhaité que
des éditions mondiales est toujours le
même genre de gestion mon mari avait
créé lui-même ses publications hors jeu
ne vous
et pas car l'autre groupe de presse
puissent changer la la la la ligne de
ses publications
finalement tout le monde est content les
compagnies d'assurance qui viennent de
faire une bonne affaire
les éditions mondiale se porte bien en
effet madame del duca qui est rassuré l'
empire créé par son mari ne sera pas
démantelée
quant aux midinettes elles continueront
chaque semaine à s' offrir du rêve à bon
marché à la sfp la société française de
production la grève commencé ce matin va
continuer jusqu'à demain soir
aucune discussion n'est envisagé ce
week-end d'après les syndicats une
assemblée générale du personnel prévue
lundi matin décidera de la suite à
donner à l'action conséquences des
émissions perturber ou supprimés sur les
trois chaînes de télévision dont le
détail vous sera communiquée par les
animatrices
la polémique continue après la sortie du
film de michel branchut le pull-over
rouge
la cour d'appel de paris a ordonné la
suppression de quatre scènes concernant
la famille remblin sept municipalités
ont déjà décidé d'interdire la
projection du film dans leur ville à
marseille les dirigeants des syndicats
des commissaires de police et le
syndicat autonome des policiers en civil
des bouches du rhône ont adressé des
télégrammes de protestation au ministre
de l'intérieur au ministre de la justice
au ministre de la culture
il estime que ce film est gravement
diffamatoires envers les services de
police qui ont mené l enquête et
appréhender le meurtrier et ses
syndicats demandent une intervention
rapide afin que toutes les séquences
diffamatoires contre la police nationale
soit interdite avec 1h n'aidèrent le
point le film de michel derache le
pull-over rouge raconte l'histoire de
l'enlèvement et de l'assassinât de la
petite maria dolorès rambla la
condamnation et l'exécution de christian
ranucci considérant que ce film portait
atteinte à leur vie privée
les parents de maria dolorès rambla ont
demandé la saisie du film avant sa
sortie dans les salles après se l'être
fait projeter le président du tribunal a
refusé au nom de la liberté d'expression
d'ordonner cette saisie et le film est
sorti comme prévu à paris mercredi
dernier sans aucune restriction après
avoir reçu au préalable son visa
d'exploitation par la commission de
censure en ordonnant la coupure de
quatre séquences la cour d'appel de
paris a en partie donné satisfaction à
la famille
ben là elle croyez-vous qu'il était
utile de rappeler à cette famille cinq
années après trois années après les
condamnations à mort de questions
ranucci la douleur qui était la sienne
croyez vous qu'il ait des tutelles de
montrer un père s'effondrer sur le corps
de sa petite fille croyez-vous qu'il
était utile de voir une mère s'effondrer
dans son appartement en apprenant que le
corps de sa fille venait d'être
découvert voyez-vous qu'il était utile
de montrer le désarroi de parents à
l'annonce de l'enlèvement de leur petite
fille enfin il s'était pas porté
atteinte à la liberté d'expression que
d'avoir voulu conserver à leur égard
cette intimité profonde existantes entre
leur douleur à ce moment précis c'est
quelque chose qui leur appartient et
qu'il n'appartient à personne d'autre
michel derache quel est votre sentiment
après la décision de la cour d'appel de
paris
il est très très ambigu mon sentiment je
suis effaré d'une décision pareille je
me plie parce que en réalité une ne fait
pas basculer mon fils me déséquilibre
pas mon film mais je veux dire que mon
film va rester là fait ghannouchi avec
tout ce que ça comporte de d'intolérance
ce qui je trouve triste c'est que je ne
pouvais pas raconter une histoire comme
ça sans prendre acte de la douleur de la
famille de la victime de marie dolorès
rambla maintenant on met on fait un film
qui est on me fait faire un film qui est
manichéen je ne parle que de la faire
annuler chi et je le regrette et je dois
signaler que c'est je crois la première
fois que un film qui est déjà sortie on
demande des coupures le le seul exemple
est un exemple qui datent de pétain et
c'était les allemands qui l'avaient
demandé sur la fille du puisatier de
pagnol
plusieurs maires ou adjoints ont décidé
en vertu de leur pouvoir de police
d'interdire la projection du film dans
leur commune c'est le cas à toulon qui
me concerne
le film qui met au pilori la police
à travers son comportement la justice à
travers ses décisions et puis en quelque
sorte je dirais remets en cause un drame
qui n'a pas trois ans d'ancienneté me
paraît pour le moins je dirais vraiment
navrant ceci étant dit je suis
respectueux bien entendu la liberté
d'expression je ne pense pas quand même
que cette liberté ne permet de dire
n'importe quoi à n'importe quel moment
et surtout de revenir sur un drame qui a
secoué énormément la provence les mieux
corse de notre ville et notre
département et de notre région et voyez
vous un tel film traitant un fait
policiers d'ici dans quelques années
pouvait peut-être passer actuellement
s'il y avait des difficultés
j'en ai eu tout à fait conscience envers
les réactions que j'ai reçu la cohésion
de la majorité est particulièrement
nécessaire à un moment où la france se
trouve dans une situation politique
difficile c'est ce que monsieur olivier
guichard député rpr de loire atlantique
a déclaré aujourd'hui à france inter le
parti des forces nouvelles réunies ce
week-end son 4ème congrès national les
dirigeants du parti des forces nouvelles
se propose de définir leur stratégie
dans la perspective des prochaines
échéances électorales et de présenter
une série de propositions pour
l'avènement d'une nouvelle droite
politique
une centaine de motards ont manifesté
cet après midi au havre pour protester
contre les menaces du ministre de
l'intérieur de confisquer les motos en
cas de nouvelles manifestations
une manifestation prudente puisque les
motards avaient laissé leurs deux roues
au garage ils ont parcouru les
principales artères du havre en planche
à roulettes en patinette et en patins à
roulettes il n'y a pas eu d'incident
demain le trafic aérien sera à nouveau
perturbé les contrôleurs aériens du
centre d'athis mons ont décidé
d'interrompre les décollages de 14h à
17h30
cependant ce soir les compagnies
aériennes déclare qu elles assureront le
maximum de vols sainte c'est ainsi qu'à
air inter au moins un aller retour sera
assuré sur toutes les grandes liaisons
pour les horaires de ces liaisons vous
pouvez appeler le 687 12-12 mais
attention la décision de faire décoller
les avions à une heure précise
appartient aux contrôleurs de la
navigation aérienne il peut donc y avoir
des retards atteignant 4 ou 5 heures en
ce qui concerne air france maintenant la
plupart des 20 des vols seront assurés
mais trois vols sont avancées rio de
janeiro
hong kong et düsseldorf et sept vols
sont annulés pour les vols d'air france
téléphoner aux 320 15,55 rugby premier
test match des all blacks ce lait tous
noirs qui sont en grande bretagne il
rencontrait aujourd'hui l'ecosse un
adversaire difficile qui s'est montré à
la hauteur pendant presque toute la
partie mais à la fin c'est la classe qui
a parlé les all-blacks ont gagné 20 à 6
alain escot b et revoici donc sur le
vieux continent les terribles all blacks
les tout noir qui l'an dernier avait
tout bousculer sur leur passage durant
leur séjour en grande-bretagne avant de
rendre l'âme chez eux à auckland le 14
juillet face à un feu d'artifice
tricolore qu'on n'est pas prêt d'oublier
en écosse aujourd'hui ils avaient à se
faire pardonner
un seul essai en première mi-temps
marqué ici par leur bridge et 3 en
deuxième période dont celui que vous
allez voir maintenant signée mecs tête
devait démontrer que même si leur équipe
était profondément
dit fier ma classe elle était toujours
la même
essai transformé par richard wilson qui
à la 46e minute du match quand tu es
donc le score à 10 à 0
bien sûr les écossais ont fait ce qu'ils
ont pu en transformant notamment les
pénalités qui leur revenaient une ici à
irvine
et une autre la part le même irvine qui
réduisait la marque à 10 à 6 et qui
laissait entrevoir qui peut-être les
choses n'étaient pas d'amis mais à dix
minutes de la fin
la bourrasque néo zélandaise allait
faire des ravages sur le vert gazon de
muret field
si les écossais pratique l'économie qui
les a rendus célèbres les all blacks que
de son avare ni de leurs efforts et de
leur talent et ce n'est pas ce que c'est
merveilleux
marquez parti en wilson qui me fera
mentir
l'essai sera transformé par l'autre
wilson richard ce qui portera la marque
à 16 à 6 est ce qui fera sombrer
définitivement les écossais oui
décidément ils iraient cet après midi à
ne rester qu'une bonne classe de
différence et en voici une dernière
l'opération anti gaspi organisé par tf1
cet après midi vient de se terminer cinq
voitures avec cinq conducteurs du monde
de l'automobile et du spectacle ont
parcouru un trajet mixte comportant de
la ville de l'autoroute et les fameuses
départementale but de l'opération
démontré qu'en changeant radicalement sa
façon de conduire
on peut rendre sa voiture beaucoup moins
gourmande le bilan avec bernard giraud
monsieur gilbert le bourdais vainqueur
cet été du concours anti gaspi s'est
avéré une fois de plus le plus économe
cet après-midi-là consommé en moyenne
durant les deux épreuves 4 litres 5 aux
100 km soit un cinquième de mois que les
autres concurrents bernard darniche
patrick de payet jacques bonne car est
producteur d'auto moto et véronique
jannot partenaires d'alain delon dans le
film le toubib darniche bonnecarrère
furent les plus rapides ce qui explique
leur forte consommation
la notion de temps n'est pas intervenu
dans notre classement les 130 km devait
être parcouru en moins de trois heures
ce test comprenait deux épreuves l'une
routière en ville sur autoroutes et sur
route secondaire et un gymkhana tracé
par la prévention routière ici
l'appareil de mesure de consommation
d'essence
et conclusion je dirais fait d'abord
l'expérience père la matière puisque
c'est le finaliste la conduite de cet
été car tenue aujourd'hui également le
meilleur résultat
est-ce que je dois dire c'est que d
autres personnes qui ont concouru et
n'avait pas pratiquer la conduite
économique en appliquant quelques
conseils simples ont obtenu des
résultats remarquables 5 litres au cent
sur ce parcours il y avait une partie
urbaine important c'était donc
exemplaire et je peux à ce titre rappelé
ce qui a été obtenu cet été par les 2000
personnes qui ont suivi ses cours de
conduite économique ils ont obtenu en
moyenne 15 % de réduction ce qui montre
bien que la conduite économie c'est
quelque chose de très réel et je précise
bien sans changer leur vitesse moyenne
de déplacement
véronique jannot a démontré qu'une femme
pouvait parfois se montrer économe en ce
qui concerne du moins la conduite
automobile l'aérospatiale vient de
gagner une nouvelle partie dans sa
conquête mondiale du marché de
l'hélicoptère l'aérospatial représente
déjà près du quart du marché mondial de
l'hélicoptère et elle vient de présenter
son dernier né l'écureuil bimoteur qui
porte le nom de twin star aux etats unis
avant même la fin des essais sur la
seule réputation de l'aérospatiale 191
exemplaire de cet hélicoptère ont été
vendus le twin star est construit comme
les autres hélicoptères de la gamme dans
les usines de marignane qui les fabrique
au rythme de 40 par mois un reportage et
une enquête de jean-paul la rivière les
faits ce sont sans aucun doute penchées
sur le berceau du dernier né des
hélicoptères de l'aérospatiale la s350 5
dont vous voyez ici le prototype en vol
au-dessus de la région de marine
avant même d'être mis en fabrication
laisse 355 aussi baptisé twinstar été
commandé à 100 exemplaires dérivés de
l'écureuil
un hélicoptère léger monoturbine de 5 6
places déjà vendues à 4 160 exemplaires
le twin star est un bi turbine léger de
même capacité qui emprunte à son aîné le
maximum d'éléments mais grâce à ses deux
turbines de 425 chevaux chacune au lieu
des 650 chevaux de l'unique turbines de
l'écureuil et à une plus grande capacité
en carburant le twin star va plus
plus loin et surtout avec une plus
grande sécurité puisqu'il peut voler sur
un seul moteur
c'est surtout cette dernière
caractéristique que souhaitaient les
clients américains de l'écureuil dont
beaucoup utilisent l'appareil pour
travailler au dessus de la mer notamment
pour la recherche et l'exploitation
pétrolière
après le succès initial du 350 écureuils
qui avait été dessinée pour le marché
civil
nous avons constaté une très forte
demande de la part des utilisateurs pour
le même appareil mais avec deux moteurs
quelle est la place de l'aérospatiale
aux états unis depuis beaucoup d'années
maintenant nous sommes intéressés aux
marchés nord américains ont marché civil
parce que c'est la moitié au moins du
marché mondial et il y a quatre ans nous
avons créé une filiale à grand prairie
près de dallas chargée de commercialiser
et de supporter nos appareils sur le
continent nord américain
et aujourd'hui cette filiale couvrent à
peu près 20%
dumas la totalité du marché civil
américain ce qui est du même extrêmement
hélicoptère de travail aérien ou de
liaison le twin stars dont le prototype
a volé pour la première fois le 28
septembre dernier 15 mois seulement
après le début de son étude sera livré
en série à la fin 2009 180 actuellement
191 exemplaires sont commandés dont la
plupart aux états unis ce qui veut dire
que le carnet est rempli jusqu'à la fin
de 1990
le temps demain dimanche de la pluie
demain matin sur la bretagne à la vendée
au cours de la journée la pluie
progressera vers l'est et gagnera le
nord et le nord-est ainsi que le massif
central les températures resteront
fraîches dans le sud ouest et dans le
midi il y aura fort heureusement un peu
de soleil à 23h35 le dernier journal
vous sera présentée par jacques nouard
bonsoir et merci